So the code you had to write was pretty straight forward.
Like most decorators, we compute the result here by applying the function to the args,
then we return the result down here.
Maybe a little bit tricky is what's in this finally clause,
which is we're decreasing the trace level.
So the indentation level goes up by 1 every time we enter a new function
and down by 1 every time we go back.
The issue here is, we want to make sure that we do decrement this.
If we increment this once, and then calling the function results in an error,
and we get thrown out of that error, we want to make sure we put it back where it belongs.
We don't want to mess with something and then not restore it.
So that's why we put this in a try finally.